when i became a mom of two girls i
finally understood the saying
that there is no harder job than being a
parent there's also
none more rewarding but sometimes you
just need a timeout
and recently i got a video message from
a woman named vincenza
who truly has her hands full check this
out
hi drew my name is vincenza i'm the mom
of five boys
triplets that are 18 and twins that are
11. my days are crazy fall super busy
you look like you always have it
together any advice you'd be willing to
share mom to mom
i loved your story so much i loved your
relationship with your husband
i love your three triplet boys 18 years
old
yes and two twin boys 11 years old
yes please tell us what is a typical day
like in vincenza's life
a typical day is just my crazy my world
and i wouldn't trade it for anything
every day you never know what's going to
come up and our main goal is to divide
and conquer
we get up first thing in the morning and
my husband says to me what's on today's
agenda you can never plan ahead when you
have five kids
you never know what obstacles are going
to come up you never know what the day
brings
so we nobody's ever left alone whether
it's a baseball game or a school
function
somebody's always there with my older
ones two just left for college so i lost
two chauffeurs
so um we are in the middle of uh
re-figuring out the schedule
but we just divide and conquer and we
make sure that everybody has everything
they need
everybody gets to every place they have
to go and we knew back then when we had
a big family that nobody would ever
suffer because we couldn't get our act
together so
um everybody's made it everywhere um
we've never missed a birthday party and
there's always been a gift in hand so i
figure that's a good day
wow i loved when you said divide and
conquer because to me that is one of the
most
empowering and powerful ingredients in
the recipe
of an awesome highly functioning
relationship
how did you guys decide to do that and
how do you execute it
well we knew right from the very
beginning we were outnumbered having
three kids at once
just when you think you have your day
completely planned out there's always
something to
turn it upside down but we've been able
to get it done
and everybody works together when do you
find time for yourself do you i
um i wouldn't have in any other way but
i feel like
i don't know what time to myself is
because if i do have time to myself
it's always am i forgetting something
did i forget something i should really i
have to go to a baseball game
there's really never any down time and
it almost becomes
a little anxiety kicks in and what am i
forgetting or where am i supposed to be
and if there's something that i think
about like the other day i wanted to get
a pedicure
my son said to me there's no food in
this house so i skipped the pedicure and
went food shopping instead
all right what is something that if you
could have one wish
and get rid of it out of the picture
what would it be laundry
absolutely laundry i read your book and
the one thing i could relate to was what
you said early on is that laundry put
you over the edge
i used to hear the jaws theme when i hit
my laundry pile
right there right there as soon as i
walk in my laundry room
it's a feat i've never been able to
accomplish
it gives me anxiety um okay so
i want to give you something i actually
made this for
an ex-boyfriend i mean literally 15
years ago
and i uh he left before i had the chance
to give it to him
and it was i took my old royal
typewriter which i still have
and i typed out on a bunch of cards
time outs for him because i thought
every relationship needs a timeout and
every person needs a timeout
so when you pull the cards out it says i
love you but i need a 24-hour timeout i
love you
but i need a and there are different
times there's ten minutes five minutes
whether it's for and with another person
or even for ourselves
to take one and gift it to ourselves so
i wanted to give it to you thank you
um and maybe you pull one out every time
you look at that laundry
pile because our other surprise is
that i got you and your husband he's
already on board by the way i completely
went behind your back i hope it's okay
we have a special surprise where this
company
called the laundry elf is actually
um giving you a 3 000 voucher for
laundry service and they're going to
come and pick
up your laundry take it away do it
and then bring it back to you and here
is a laundry bag for you
i cannot believe i just got laundry
service
and then i have a message from your
husband if that's okay let me
show you lots of surprises three
surprises hey hon
hope you're having a great day today
just want to let you know that every
once in a while
someone deserves a timeout and you
definitely deserve it you've been
working your butt off for the past six
months
actually for the past 18 years with our
triplets now going off to school
anytime you want to use one of those
tickets from the timeout jar
you got it love you babe
there's your mr dividend conquer your
co-pilot
who has a real lesson to teach us all
about
how to be in high functioning
relationships really i i just think what
you guys are doing is so inspiring
i'm like uh a fanatic single person
watching you guys it makes me want to be
in a great relationship everybody had a
good guy
i did and that's why i can get it done
except for laundry well guess what
we have got you there at least for that
thank you
thank you so much it's been a pleasure
thank you i'm so glad to make your
acquaintance
[Music]
you